سأجلس على الرمال لكنني لن أذهب
إلى الماء
قبل اليوم ، أحب بريان سيتز البالغ من العمر ثماني سنوات
اللعب على الرمال
والاستمتاع بالسباحة في المحيط
إلى جانب أن العائلة كانت تخطط
لقضاء إجازتها في شاطئ ميرتل منذ أكثر من  بعد عام ،
شعرت
بشيء أعتقد أنه عضني ونظرت
إلى أسفل وكان هناك سمكة قرش على ذراعي
وكنت فقط في مياه الصرف الصحي وواصلت
الضغط عليها لإخراجها من
ذراعي كما تعلم ، ثم حدث ذلك
وكان ذلك بعد الظهر في أول
يوم كامل في إجازتهم عندما كانت
رحلتهم تأخذ منعطفًا صادمًا لم أتمكن
حتى من رؤية القرش قادمًا
ولكن كل ما رأيته هو أنها
كانت سمكة القرش التي
قفزت ولم تعض حتى  على طول الطريق
كما رأيت حركة ذيله مثل
الذهاب إلى الجانب
ثم هناك
ذهبت كما لو كانت تصرخ قليلاً
ولكن بمجرد أن تلمسها
سقطت في الماء ، كانت الفتاة
البالغة من العمر ثماني سنوات فقط  على بعد 10 أقدام
من جدته عندما
شاهدها يلدغها منجل سمكة قرش  تم نقلها
إلى مستشفى محلي حيث خضعت لعملية
جراحية وحصلت على مئات
الغرز ، فمن الواضح جدًا أنها عضة سمكة قرش
عندما تنظر إلى فن علامات الأسنان
والضرر الذي حدث
وتعاطفي مع الضحية ، فهذا
أمر مروع.  من خلال دانيال
أبول ، أستاذ علوم البحار في
جامعة كارولينا الساحلية ، يقول إن
أسماك القرش ليست شائعة في هذا الوقت من
العام ، وإذا كنت تخطط للسباحة في
منزلهم ، فهناك بعض الاحتياطات التي
يجب عليك اتخاذها جيدًا حتى لا تسبح عند الفجر
والغسق.  الناس في
الماء ، وبعض أسماك القرش
أقرب إلى إطعام الشواطئ ،
لا يسبحون حيث توجد مجموعات من
الأسماك الصغيرة تسمى أسماك الطعم في
الخارج
، حيث تسبح أسماك القرش خارجها
ولا تسبح بالقرب من المكان الذي يصطاد فيه الناس كما هو
الحال في  يقول أبيل إن لدغات أسماك القرش
نادرة للغاية ، وبينما يقدم
تعاطفه مع ضحايا لقاءات أسماك القرش
، من المهم أن نفهم أن أسماك القرش
ضرورية لنظامنا البيئي ، فمن المهم جدًا
بأننا نتعامل مع أسماك القرش ومحيطنا
وكوكبنا بأكمله باحترام أكثر مما
نفعل الآن ،
نقول إن لقاءها مع أسماك القرش لن
يمنعها من الاستمتاع بالشاطئ ، فهي
تحتاج فقط للشفاء والحصول على كل الوضوح من
أطبائها
في ميرتل بيتش كاميل  أخبار gayle abc 15